Peace be upon and sisters and friends hope
you guys are doing well welcome to my
show it's water yeah no rations please
now as you guys know reach 100,000
subscribers i got a special video for
you guys a funny one you guys would
really like it i'  m going to go i'm going
to let you guys see that straight away
i'm not going to make this video too
long you know i want you all you guys to
please be tuned in little reminder we are
going to benefit from this as well  as
well as we going to have a fun few fun
videos i'm going to share with you guys
inall um which you guys find fun in sha
and also wea wea now and what he has said
about regarding my 100,000 subscribers
maybe you know he  might have some words
of inspiration or you know what we might
actually like prank him should we prank
him i'll ring him on private yeah we're
going to do that let watch the video
first this is a special video from me to
you guys  but let's watch it so there you
go
guys
so yeah guys hope you guys enjoy that
video as you guys can see you know
actually this guy called nr whatever he
called sal i think he st idea from me
actually you know as you can see my
cutting skills you can see a big
resemblance you know this whole sal
thing he added it on but yeah i'm
joking i'm joking so basic hope you guys
like that video i hope you guys it funny
i want to show you guys that  video
because you know we have a s hum as well
yes we practice does we boring people
doesn't mean we just you know you know
life is boring and all we do is you
know pray and this is the purpose you know
we want to make the religion  fun for us
you keep un mus sometimes he says things
that upset me the video to in a minute for
guys
come 20 minutes we're going to be there
we do meet and greet come and give us
hugs come on don't think let's
[laughter  ]
go put your sword down okay guys a few
steps to in car as a muslim you have the
ke you have the
ign and a few
wires [
laughter] [
music]
you just killed me
brother i think time
you
God priv let see what  happens let's see
it will work let see if it will
work
[Music]
say hell hello must where are
you musta where are
youa where are you
oh my god are you coming to see me no
why would i come and see you get abd and
come see
me musa yes did you know me obviously
man ja come
on did you really me how you with your
voice no but it sounded a bit different
no no no didn't man it sounded like you
what are you talking about oh man i need
to work on it anyways listen yeah listen
man i'm doing my video regarding
reaching 100,000 subscribers and i
thought i call you i i call you live on
camera but it didn't work do you want to
say anything to the viewers masallah he
come a  long way to tell one thing i
remember yeah i remember once we were in
the car and ali we were driving and ali
does something and he's like oh no and
then he he knocks on the dashboard of
his car and i'm like what are you  doing
he like touch w oh yeah yeah
yeah that's first
first
take from
holland
salam mustfa
mustfa
hello is this mustfa
musta is this mustfa
nej deta nej nej nej can speak english i
can't
[laughter]
understand listen listen listen i'  m
recording i'm recording this 100000
subscriber video live not live but on
camera but i'm going to put [
laughter]
it i don't
guys you need
to when are you
coming as you see guys me and don't work
why i don't us do
now m swiftly now guys the reason why i
to do this video mainly is because
you guys heard it and was upset with me
now um is that basically now reach
100,000 subscribers yes it's a good
thing it's amazing  a lot of people the
dream like oh you know i want to reach
subscribers or a million or whatever it
may be we need to understand as
youtubers we carry responsibility this
is really important and a lot of muslim
youtubers don't understand that and i
don't  't mean to like obviously it's good
that we reached there everything's going
positive i just want to give like a
little reminder so we all benefit from
insallah as well yeah is that this comes
from response with responsibilities
because i need to look at those 100,000
Subscribers and millions like millions
of people that watch the videos and I
need to think to myself is this for me
or against me because it looks all happy
in life this is really crucial sometimes
we think you know having success money
cars this whatever it may be  and there's
nothing wrong with that as you earn
in a halal way and you do for the
sake of allah etc.
however in the real we think things are
going like things are happ this that it
does mean happy can be can i'm not  say
say not all the time you can't say okay
i got subscribers do right on my side no
you don't know so the reason why i say
is it for me against me i can only find
the find
out one guys
pleas i  do it for the right reasons and
that my intentions are right because if
it isn't these 100,000 subscribers is
actually against me because under the
people are you misguided us whatever
even we try to do best regard you qur
you the best of ability you i  'm try to
say and we try to follow it how the how
the sal how the understood and this is
how it should be l misguidance comes
from that why because we don't the
and how underst things when we start to
own interpretation  things we go so i
try to sck to that but yes i don't like
some people come you know like i don't
follow it the strict way
because if they look at them times but
mann so important is
onead a of
ascribe unfortunately sad you know  basic
e basic mansh and that's the i don't
want to take
this position isam as much as i can that's
why guys are important life what you do you
do sanal said against
askit
my,
God willing, the work that we do and
you guys  can this was i
give said
life that from you so guys that's about
really you know hope you guys enjoyed
the two videos and the little phone
calls that i did and guys thank you for
watching thanks for being with me all
the way we had ups  and downs and where
we be in the future may God keep firm
in the religion keep us guided in and
that's about it you know there any
recomendation you want to give me for my
youtube channel any new video any advice
I appreciate do comment the section
below  may bless every sle one of you
guys
message of May God’s peace, mercy, and
blessings be upon me,
good